monsieur jean paul huchon bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
c'est un premier jour un petit peu
spécial les conditions exceptionnelles
qui s'est tenue hier ces municipales
quel bilan faites-vous justement de ces
municipales fallait-il finalement tenir
ces élections
hier
écoutez le la tension est énorme et
c'est jamais vu est-ce qu'il fallait
tenir ces élections a patiemment où le
gouvernement avait des informations sur
l'accélération de l'épidémie il aurait
mieux valu en effet les reporté de
quelques mois
lorsque nous seront sortis de fête
tornade voilà donc je pense que ça c'est
la première constatation deuxième
constatation pour les votants il ya eu
une grande confiance
la plupart du temps au maire sortant
quelle que soit leur étiquette et je
note une bonne performance notamment
du parti socialiste et de ses alliés
évidemment une grosse percée des
écologistes en particulier dans des
huiles importante ou voiliers note
importante donc il y a de ce fait la
république en marche a plutôt subi un
échec
et évidemment c'est particulier on
manifeste à paris où là maintenant anne
hidalgo à la voile et vend quelque 106
elle fait alliance avec les écologistes
pour le reste on note que certaines
performances sont impressionnantes
notamment des écologistes à strasbourg à
lyon à bordeaux et que par ailleurs il
ya beaucoup de mairies socialistes à
nantes à rennes
qui ont bien tenu le coup et il ya une
inconnue comme d'habitude à marseille où
il est possible que la liste de gauche
en pente face au successeur de jean
claude gaudin donc globalement une
élection municipale intéressante qui a
conforté beaucoup de positions deux
sortants mais qui a provoqué un retour
des partis traditionnels et en
particulier de ceux qui étaient les plus
attachés évidemment à l'heure à leur
terroir et en particulier je le dirai
encore des socialistes avec cette grande
progression des écologistes
quant à aux républicains vont ils font
pas de miracles mais mais ils se sont
maintenus dans beaucoup de lui il faut
savoir qu'en 2014 s'il avait gagné
énormément de ville alors le scrutin a
surtout ce premier tour a surtout été
marqué par un taux d'abstention record
on l'a vu un
plusieurs politiques même avant les
résultats ont demandé le report du
second tour on sait que le président de
la république va prendre la parole ce
soir pour annoncer peut-être de
nouvelles mesures face à la propagation
du coronavirus est-ce que c'est
envisageable ce report du second tour
qu'est ce que cela voudrait dire est ce
que on risque de recommencer en fait les
élections depuis le début si jamais le
second tour et décalé
alors je crois qu'il ya ceux qui ont été
élus au premier tour c'est difficile de
les priver de leur victoire et par
conséquent faudra faire en deux temps si
on devait remporter les élections il
faudra le faire en deux temps
pour ceux qui ont été élus et ceux qui
n'ont pas été ou qui sont encore en
compétition
je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient majeur en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que compte
tenu de la propagation de l'épidémie
et compte tenu des risques que ça fait
courir à la santé des français
on peut par ailleurs on ne peut pas
plaisanter avec ça il faut prendre les
choses très sérieusement et ça veut dire
que le deuxième tour est assez largement
compromis très bien en tout cas merci
beaucoup
jean paul huchon d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien président de la région il